bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo
alors je vous avoue qu'à la base je
n'étais pas vraiment épais par faut
qu'on ait le soldat l'hiver tout
simplement car on sort d'une grosse
pause du mc eu du mal heureusement à la
pandémie est également car rwanda vision
a fait un retour en force et a vraiment
tout cas c'est quoi mais je suis
agréablement surpris moi qui m'attendais
à une simple série d'actions avec une
simple prise de conscience de sam par
rapport au bouclier et bien la série a
amené de nombreux personnages
intéressants des thématiques touchante
et importante de beaux messages est
évidemment une évolution de ses anciens
personnages
cependant même si la série est cool etc
on ne peut pas nier une chose c'est que
le grand final
et quand même flou genre vraiment flow
quoi voir n'apporte pas grand chose pour
la suite des événements et c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'a
questionné comme marvel termine toujours
ses productions en grande pompe avec de
gros scène post-générique un calendrier
défini des liens entre les oeuvres et
cetera
mais ici ce n'est pas vraiment le cas on
ne sait pas dans quelle direction vont
aller sam et bucky pareil pour walker
devenu usa john tu ou bien même sharon
carter qui possède sa propre scène post
générique
nous savons juste qu'elle est power
broker al'inverse si nous comparons avec
wendat vision nous savons d'entrée que
la série va découler sur le film de dr
strange 2 et le multivers de la folie
nous avons deux scène post générique
avec une direction pour monica rambo ou
encore
un maximum et c'est ça le petit souci
qui lie avec la série de faux qu'on ne
sait pas à quoi c'est lié on ne sait pas
sur quoi cela va déboucher et cela
explique donc tout ce flou qu'apporte la
fin néanmoins il existe une potentielle
réponse qui m'est venue à la fin de la
série et qui semble être confirmée par
certains sites
n'oubliez pas que la pandémie a vraiment
chamboulé les plans de marvel studios et
il existe un film qui en souffrent
beaucoup
c'est black widow black widow a été
conçue pour être la première oeuvre de
la phase 4 nous amenant donc de nombreux
éléments qui auraient dû être traités
par la suite avec les productions
suivante je parle bien évidemment de la
série de faucon pour la comparaison
c'est comme si nous avions eu docteur
strange 200 la sortie de one la vision
nous verrions le dark old agatha
harkness possiblement les véritables
pouvoirs de luanda mais sans savoir
véritablement d'où ils viennent nous
avons cas ici dans falcon avec le
personnage de valentina allegra des
fontaines un personnage qui dans les
comics est une taupe russe incrusté dans
le shield ce personnage a été teasé par
marvel comme ayant une grande place dans
l'avenir du mc et elle sera normalement
présentes dans black widow
évidemment comme chaque personnage
provenant des comics son histoire
complète ne peut être retranscrite
mais elle semble avoir gardé son côté
russe notamment par rapport à ses
origines dans les comics et sa présence
dans black widow qui va amener le centre
d'espionnage soviétique
la red room et pour aller encore plus
loin il est fortement possible que
valentina est donc john walker travail
pour thunderbolt ross et c'est peut-être
même le cas pour agent carter
souvenez-vous que ross est à l'origine
des accords de soko vie il voulait
prendre le contrôle des avengers mais
aussi il a toujours été en quête de la
recréation du sérum du super soldat
deux éléments qui symbolise jon walker
un héros docile et avec du sérum en lui
c'est un personnage très important dans
les comics qui deviendra un super vilain
et dans le m c'est une nous savons que
ce dernier est également liée à black
widow dans son film il est possiblement
celui qui l'a recueillie après civil war
est envoyé en russie mais il est aussi
présent lors des obsèques de tony stark
ce qui nous montre clairement que le
personnage est toujours actif et vivant
étant donné que carter en tant que power
broker chercher avec le scientifique
nagl a recréé le sérum c'était peut-être
sous les ordres de ross car évidemment
c'était une obsession pour lui ce sérum
et tous les projets entourant les super
soldats ont été stoppés et bizarrement
le power broker ne chercher que ça
financer les recherches du scientifique
sur le sérum alors par rapport à la
nouvelle sharon carter qui a infiltré le
gouvernement américain tu as des us qui
est toujours caché
l'arrivée de us à junk avec valentina et
bien nous pourrions faire face à une
sorte d'hydre à 2.0 pour le mc u9 il
trompa cette fois ci le shield mais
directement le gouvernement américain et
du coup pour revenir plus précisément
sur john walker en tant qu agent il va
devenir le rival principal de sam le
nouveau captain america et si les liens
avec black widow sont fondées il ya
peut-être de fortes chances que
taskmaster et john walker travaille dans
le même groupe
mais bon je m'avance un petit peu l'âge
l'année dans tous les cas walker va
servir de porte de sortie pour sam en
tant que nouveau captain america à un
captain america moderne qui correspond
bien à son époque et au vu de
l'intrusion de rue sous d'autres
criminels dans le gouvernement
d'ailleurs pourrait découler sur la
série de six crête inve jeunes et bien
il semblerait qu'aujourd'hui les héros
sont de plus en plus mêlée à la
politique encore plus qu'à l'époque de
civil war on imagine fortement une
confrontation entre sam captain america
et john walker us agent avec chacun
leurs fans et leurs partisans
enfin si nous voulons entrer dans de
petites théories concernant la série
bones qui commence a épousé de plus en
plus sa nouvelle identité en tant que
white wolf est en larmes qui a tué le
roi chaka bug qui a été recueillie par
les oies quand des sécheries elle même
pendant la crise au stade du personnage
qui réussira à l'aider à se libérer de
sa facette de soldats de l'hiver sans
oublier tout le travail
dayot pour le côté psychologique
évidemment tout ce travail a découlé des
décisions de tshala le roi du wakanda et
black panthères ce qui signifie qu'une
liaison entre les deux personnages
existent jamais souri ou la garde
rapprochée du roi n'aurait agi sans les
ordres de ce dernier à terme nous avons
donc de fortes chances de voir bucky
retourner au wakanda certainement pour
black panther 2 avec cette fois ci une
toute nouvelle identité un nouveau
costume et très certainement de
nouvelles possibilités de combat avec
son bras c'est quelque chose de très
important pour les héros de marvel pour
leur révolution et afin qu'il ne stagne
pas et donc qu'il gagne en puissance
aussi nous avons eu le cas avec sam avec
sa prise de conscience et surtout la
reprise du bouclier le tour de bugs qui
va arriver prochainement
puis il est temps de terminer sur la
rive et d'encore un nouveau et yang
adventures à la manière de tommy et
billy dans one d'avis jeunes qui eux
aussi font partie des young avengers
dans les comics nous avons cette fois ci
l'arrivée discrète délit bradley le
petit-fils d'isaiah bradley et
sincèrement la question aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas est-ce qu'il y aura les young
avengers mais plutôt quand seront ils
tous présentés est réuni néanmoins c'est
possiblement la partie où nous avons le
- d'information car nous savons que et
lee bradley et à young avengers mais
comment va-t-il le devenir dans le mc
par rapport au mémorial créé pour son
grand père à isaiah et le nouveau
symbole qu'est devenue sa main en tant
que nouveau captain america elie
souhaiterait lui aussi pourquoi pas
prendre part au combat et en inspirer
néanmoins ce dernier n'est pas supposé
avoir de super pouvoirs à part avec le
sérum du super soldat
ce qui dans la logique veut dire que
soit marvel va développer tout le côté
héritage génétique dans le sens où elie
a des super pouvoirs car son grand père
en a et c'est une question qui n'a
jamais été répondu est montré dans les
films d'ailleurs soit la question du
sérum n'est toujours pas bouclé et il
existe encore des moyens d'en créer et
là impossible de liens avec sharon est à
des us peut se faire mais là encore une
fois toutes les intrigues entre elles
écoutez je pense avoir dit tout ce que
j'avais en tête je vous avoue que je
n'ai pas parlé d'eux est nommé à part
dire que sa survie traduit son retour
dans le futur possiblement balle j'ai
pas grand chose en tête le concernant
mais nous aurons l'occasion de reparler
de tout ça dans de prochaines vidéos
j'espère néanmoins que celle-ci déjà
vous aura plu vous éclairant un petit
peu sur l'avenir du mc hué en vous
donnant envie de vous y intéresser
davantage
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous avez
préféré dans la série que ce soit un
personnage un moment particulier autres
moi par exemple c'est john walker
personnellement toute l'intrigué et le
fond du personnage c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui m'a plu cette image du
bout
lier ensanglanté était vraiment
phénoménal et menaçant bref n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner de laisser un petit
pouce bleus de me suivre sur instagram
ou twitter et puis bah écoutez c'était
argot rock et que le lionheart soit avec
vous allez ciao tout le monde
liot je me permets de faire cette petite
interruption à la toute fin de la vidéo
car pendant le montage de celle ci une
énorme info vient de tomber et bas à
celle annonce de captain america 4
c'est une info de ouf et j'ai eu peur
que cela remette en doute mon
raisonnement du début de la vidéo par
rapport à la pseudo liaison inexistante
de la série faucon avec les autres
productions de marvel mais en aucun cas
au contraire cela rajoute du contenu lié
à black widow et faucons et du coup
pourquoi pas potentiel retour de steve
rodgers
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
avec de belles théories fin bref voila
merci et ciao tout le monde
[Musique]